have you guys ever got pulled over by
with multiple other people other cars
the same violation oh no that's weird I
got pulled over with four other cars I
thought he was pulling over everyone
else he pulled over two people behind me
and I was like damn that sucks then he
pulls up to me and he's like pull over I
was like me I and then he gives us all
the same ticket what was the ticket so
when you're trying to get into the left
lane oh you can't be gay yeah you can't
be gay it was like this fight my lip too
hard while I was turning he saw the cop
roll on the window pull over
where
bite my finger we all crossed the yellow
line to make the green left turning
light oh but I was like go yourself yeah